i got shot on the helmet
so the bullet came in there it went all
the way around and came out of the top
does it feel strange looking at peaceful
equipment it saved your life yeah it
does yeah
[Music]
yeah um
an inch lower and i won't be here now
beautiful
that's all we need one two one
okay
so
you ready to go greg yes yeah
okay so tell us a little bit about where
you grew up
um i grew up in cheltenham
mainly in the countryside
just a country boy
i didn't have a bad childhood at all you
know my mother brought me horses
so she loved dogs and animals so we
lived on this big sort of animal
sanctuary
and we had horses pigs goats god knows
what and i was riding from the age of
five years old
and i remember my grandad always used to
say to me you know
get a trade get a trade
get trade do something with your life so
what did you end up doing in the army um
just a normal household cavalry trooper
out in the mountain regiment
and then i did five years there and then
i went to windsor
where i discovered
my forte in life which was snipering
so let's let's talk about the process to
become a sniper yeah so
what is
for a normal job you fill an application
form you go for an interview what is the
application to become a sniper
um you have to do an in-test um and it's
a
well my my case we had to do a an eight
mile speed march with um 85
pound on our backs which is pretty heavy
because it's usually eight miles and
it's usually 50 pound but as a sniper
you're carrying more kit so they're
testing your robustness and we have to
do an
hour and a half normally it's two hours
but like i said before you have to be an
a1 soldier so they're pushing you to
your limit and then they do
a basic fitness test
but
they're saying instead of aiming for 60
60 60 press up 60 sit-ups and a mile and
a half running nine and a half minutes
we want you to do 100 press-ups we want
you to 100 setups we want to do a mile
and a half in nine minutes you know they
push you to your limit and then you go
through a basic field craft
and they test your knowledge
on field craft which you've got to be
100 not and then they test your map
reading and they dump you in the middle
of
in the middle of wales somewhere in the
black mountains and you've got
checkpoints to go to and that's even
before you even started the sniper phase
you know and moving on
just explain to you always field craft
field craft is
like camouflaging concealment uh knowing
uh the the crack and thump of a bullet
how far that bullet's away huge for the
crack and the thump that it gives and
the thumb is just the
supersonic uh effect of that round and
breaking the sound barrel and that's
what gives you that
the thump
um
mainly just camouflaging concealment a
lot and moving through the ground how
you move there's different ways on your
belt buckle crawling you do the monkey
crawl
or you can just do the ghost walk where
you've been really quiet moving things
out of the way with your feet or you're
just normal patrolling you know
in my eyes field craft knowing your
surroundings blending into your
surroundings
you know not being seen
that's a big bit breaking your
silhouette down you know knowing from a
distance
what's wrong you know nothing black in
nature nothing no straight lines in
nature i was quite unlucky really
because when i was a kid
like i said i was a loner and i lived in
cheltenham and we lived in the
countryside so my countryside skills
were me and my mate we used to muck
around hiding and doing things so yeah i
wouldn't say i was one step ahead but i
sort of knew my surroundings a bit
what was the sniper element of the trip
uh so basically you do the the range
first so to learn how to use the sniper
rifle to learn how to use the scope
uh and you're just on a range basically
shooting at targets so you do short
range mid range and long range
so short range would be off the top of
my head would be
you zero in at 200
to make sure your scopes and then you go
to
500
and then
mid range will be 500 to
800 and then long range will be 800 to a
kilometer away
and there's only a few ranges in england
that you can do that and one of them is
in bisley and that's where we did our
training mainly in bisley it doesn't
matter if it was absolutely hammering it
down how cold it was how wet it was
you're out on the ground and you've got
a ghillie suit on as well and you're not
even touching sniper in phase yet and if
you fail the shooting part
you're out
and you've got to get 95 percent or
above to get it
you know and
and if you fail that you don't progress
onto the sniper bit and then you move on
to obviously the sniper phase which is
you've got seven phases obviously every
member of top of my head you got you've
got navigation you've got map reading
you've got sniper knowledge you've got
observation
um you've got
your
camouflaging concealment and your
stalking there we go
um
and you you have to pass all them i
think it's 95
pass on each one
like your stalks you go on a stalk and
they try and find you basically
and there's a walker behind you and with
a radio
and they will
you've got an op and they're looking for
you basically and it's big game of hide
and seek and it's
it's hard you've got a barrier where
you're not allowed to shoot from you've
got a like um
another place where
you can stalk
and then you're not allowed beyond a
certain point so they know where you're
going to be because they've done these
talks forever you know at the schools
so you just gotta be one step ahead of
them you know
the most high-end game of hide-and-seek
it is it is yeah yeah and getting paid
for it
yeah
just asking all the answers come down
the barrel yeah sorry
naturally everything yeah yeah
i don't know
i point them that way
um so
remember the first mission you were sent
on last night yeah i can it was in iraq
we were getting
mortared constantly we're in the maisan
desert and the maisan desert is a vast
vast
place and it's desolate
you know um the only thing that attack
you in the morning is dung beetles and
that's about it sound like spitfires
that's the only bit of wildlife or
or anything alive you'll see
but we were getting
scouted
by
um a motorbike and every time we saw
this motorbike loads of mortars would
come in and it was our sop as soon as
the wagon stopped on you know
digger foxhole and everyone's got the
different sops but we had hours
and we just dig and
it had to be knee-deep so you'd enough
to you you can get into it but lads were
digging them way deeper because
the artillery and the mortars were
getting pretty damn close
and then i got the green light to um
take the target out
um i saw
he was on a motorbike
the hardest bit about the shot was
heat shimmer
because if you ever see somebody walking
in the desert they look slightly they
look really tall and as they come
towards you they shrink to their normal
size
so
he was 675 yards away
and
i got the green light and i shot
um missed my first shot second shot i
got him
and i led him on the motorbike a little
bit
in the scope you've got little dots
called mil dots and i led him
two mil dots
on the on the scope and um yeah i shot
him and then i had to go up to the body
to to see if i'd um
if he he was you know dead
and i remember walking up to the body um
the motorbike
was still revving because the um
the uh i'm not too sure what was that
called
the throttle was stuck in the sand and
the bike was revving an ak strap to it
and uh the guy was
on the floor and
he was trying to grab his radio
um
which was the icon we call icon chat and
there's an icon radio and he was trying
to grab it and then he he passed away
um he had shot him here
yeah
weird weird feeling weird feeling you
feel like you're in trouble
you feel
i've just killed someone
i feel in trouble and that feeling never
left you
so basically you go into the battlefield
to get information you've got all these
optics to your hand you've got a scope
you've got a spot in scope you've got
binoculars you've got everything so you
can get a lot of information of a target
and then once you gather that
information of a target then you either
take the target out or
um sf special forces will go in or
soldiers would go in on the patrol and
take that target out and then they get
dealt with you know
but it's not all about killing
yes it's a messy job sniper and you end
up in
um i dug a
like a trough between my legs and
i had saws down here and inside my legs
obviously you're
you're just quite acidic as well you
know um off well not acidic but
it does end up rubbing
and
so i ended up getting this trough and
the heat would just bake it and get rid
of it but you had to flies round you and
i was eating um
you get biscuits in the ration packs and
they're designed to clog you up so i was
just eating them
as much as i could trying to not
pray and i didn't want to go for a sh
so you don't move at all not at that
case you know i didn't no i was there
just getting information and intel
yeah
is that
that must be tough mentally it is
because your joints start seizing up as
well and um
you have to keep your mind occupied um
you have to
and what i used to do is make stories up
so i'd look for my scope i'd see
a bloke come out of his compound with
his
with a lady and
i would
make up the story say oh there's limpy
john with his wife you know and oh yeah
here comes his 90 kids and all that you
know and it keeps your mind occupied and
goes oh let's see what bevel's doing and
then you go over to bevel oh let's see
what bob's doing oh yeah there's bob
doing the same old thing and you get to
know their routine it's like i said you
get to know lifetime information of the
battlefield and that's your main role
you know one of your main roles and the
secondary role is to take that target
out and it's quite hard really because
when you do get to take the target out
you're killing bob
you know and you've made a name up for
him for the last four days
you know but that's the sort of thing
you need to mentally switch off
and then
while we're talking about the disgusting
things of the job then about in terms of
paying in the distance you said you said
snipers working in pairs yes they do
yeah so can you explain that for me they
work in pairs you have one and a number
two now number two is usually
the best sniper
because he'll work out all your
calculations he'll work out all the wind
here work out all the
everything you need to know for your
scope and basically then he will tell
you to put it in and all you've got to
do is pull the trigger the number one is
probably the best shooter
but me and my number me and my mate we
used to swap over all the time you know
but it gets to the point where you do
need a poo and
you can't really move you can't take
your eye off the glass you've got to
keep on target so you just roll over and
he helps you basically he's um we'll put
a little tupperware tub under your bum
off he goes he'll wipe you and then you
crack on with your mission i said that's
how important snipering is
you know you're dedicated to the job and
then you would get that you'd wrap it up
and then you put it in your backpack you
take everything with you you don't leave
anything behind
[Music]
you had the world record yeah can we
talk about that mission and about what
happened
yeah
this was early on in the tour
my last tour
we had to give overwatch for the afghan
army to move into this village
now the afghan army were the mixture of
british soldiers helping them train
so this was just a mission to go into
this village to move insurgents out they
were coming in from the left
and the village was obviously on the
right
i was stuck on the high ground and i had
four vehicles behind me
and it was an option
to um just to give overwatch or spread
my lads across the ridgeline but i just
wanted to keep them all together because
i could see everything
the officer was there
and he
could see
that in the village itself was just full
of insurgents absolutely full of them
and he warned the the patrol was walking
into a kill zone now a kill zone is
where it's easy to kill you basically
it's a zone of land where it's open
you've got nothing to hide
or nowhere to hide so i say and then
they can just mow you down and that's
the kill zone
and they moved into this kill zone and
they got opened up on
um and they were stuck
in this plow field
in the ground
and that's when i started
snipering
and i could see a flicker
in the distance
and i couldn't work out what it was
anywhere i've got my scope on to the uh
the flicker and it was a an insurgent
with a radio
hitting the flicker was the antenna
and he was contacting should say contact
and he was um
talking to the insurgents in the village
and i had an interpreter with me
and he had the radio tuned into his
radio and he can hear him talking it's
called icon chatter
as i was looking at the lads in the
vehicle see if they were getting out
because no shots were getting fired i
could see
random splashes
happening and i was wondering what they
were
and i was looking everywhere everywhere
that i engaged the target i was looking
i couldn't find anything the only place
i didn't look is where i saw the guy
with the radio and i looked up and i
could see two guys with a pkm
belt fed
washing machine gun
and they were hammering down on the lads
and um
[Music]
i was
i thought i need to sort this out
and it was a long way
it was
2475 meters away which is just over a
mile and a half now my rifle only shoots
1500 meters
so i had to
i caught it lobbing
i lobbed the bullet in
uh took me nine shots to get there
because i was bracketing and what
bracketing is is that you fire the first
shot see where it lands add a bit more
on add a bit more on add a bit more
until you hit it and i managed to hit
the compound wall so i fired one my
first shot
because i knew the calculations to put
on the scope and where to look on my
scope because i fired nine shots in the
earlier on in the morning
so i fired
and i could see it just hit next to him
so i fired again
as i fired again he stood up
and i i hit him here he fell backwards
and then the second guy stood up and i
fired a third shot and as i fired my
third shot i moved my rifle across and i
fought a full shot
so now i've got two bullets in the air
at the same time
third one missed fourth one hit him and
it hit him in the side now i didn't know
i built the world record
i didn't know at all
i didn't know until my medals parade do
you feel proud of that i'd say that's
like is that was i more of a pride for
you do you achieve something uh no
not at all doing my job trying to save
12 guys that was it flat burst
are there anything to stand on your head
as dangerous or
one mission
um well there's quite a few actually
i've done quite a few missions with my
because you work as a pair
um i work with my
my mate
and
he's still in
he's not going to say his name but he's
a a good bloke and me and him done a lot
together
and um
one mission we were in
basra palace and we got go to this place
called the p-jock and the p-drop
basically is just run by 15 people
that's it
and it's next to a prison and it used to
get smashed every single night from
11 o'clock at night or five in the
morning it is the gates of hell
the gates of hell and they're trying to
release
all these insurgents all these other
hierarchy um
taliban from this prison and it was our
job to not let him do that and
from baswa palace to the p-jock it's a
15-15 minute walk
not much by a vehicle it's two and a
half hours
because you got absolutely whacked
and um
yeah we got smashed we lost the track on
the vehicle
so the rear vehicle had to push us
and then the
the drive our vehicle just stopped and
um
we realized that the driver had been
shot through this little
slit where his hatch was he had been
shot on the head
and the commander was trying to sort him
out
um
we got hit on the vehicles you have uh
reactive armor and also impact armor
and they're like grates on the side of
the wagon and rpgs get caught with them
and the rounds get caught and we have
three rpgs caught in the side of the
wagon and they were fizzing as well
but
luckily due to the vehicle behind us it
pushed us into the p-jock
and and that's
when
sniping came into its own
we were
on the roof
on this occasion
and they came from
north they came from the south they came
from the east they came from the west
they came from everywhere
and um we ran out of gun ammo
sorry gun oil
and we end up putting on the bowels
trying to cool them down we're using
chip oil from the cookhouse
and
we get a phone called a paradigm phone
and
in the pedroc itself it was like an
old-fashioned phone you know the old
like batman phone it was red
and it was always down the bottom of the
steps
and
we got absolutely
i'm gonna say we got absolutely smashed
we thought we were gonna get overrun
so i phoned tanya
i get a bit upset you know sorry
um
i phoned her and she answered
and um
and i said to her i love you you know
then she goes i know she
goes what's what noise
and i said that has nothing that's
nothing
i said i'll phone you in the morning i
promise you i'll phone you in the
morning
just want to hear a voice you know
just want to hear
her voice
and we went back on the roof and yeah we
wouldn't we won the day we went the
night we won the fight
with your wife
yeah i did yeah
yeah
i didn't really tell her what was going
on we just had a little chat i said i
just had a little
little um little wobble what's to call
it a little wobble just wanted to hear
your voice that was all you know it's
tough out here it's because yeah i'm
always here for you
like like she is now you know i want you
to lift your head up and look at the
orange label for 10 seconds
all right
uh what just crack on here yeah yeah um
this is a smitten spender's uh scope
it's german made
um i think the best scopes it's nice
clear glass when i say clear glass when
you look through it it's like looking
through your eyeballs you know you get
other
other makes of um
scopes but this is one the military get
issued
this is a um
a 5 by 25 by um
56 magnification and it goes in the
glass
and the 56 is the is the front
and then you got the 25 which is the
center and then you got the five which
is the uh the back bit
and this is one i used on tour
and it's got different add-on like this
this this reel here this is the um
the deflection so this is left and right
and on top you've got the elevation
and on top of there you've got another
spigot and if i spin that around
it should go yellow
there we go
and that means you're on the top reading
so if i look at this scope at the full
range you can go 26
so
in theory it should be able to shoot
you know over two over two k's away
you've got a rail this is zero moa moa
is minute of angle so this one's flat
but you can get ones that have got
different angles on for
you they start from um
go up to 45 minute of angle which is
quite high mainly for long range
shooting
here i've got a spirit level
to make sure when i'm shooting i'm not
on a cant
now a can is when the rifle's on the
tilt if the rifle's on the tilt the
bullet's not going to travel straight
it doesn't the bullet doesn't travel
straight anyway it curves because inside
the barrel you've got rifling and that
rifling goes right
all right this is where it gets
complicated so it goes right so when you
fire the bullet it will eventually just
go right
all the way and bend right over and
that's where you have to use your
deflection to put more left on so the
bullet then will come central
and that's how it works
over a thousand yards
and then you have the karaos effect of
the world
taking effect
from the center i think the world moves
1050 miles an hour and as it goes higher
and lower to the north and south pole
slower it gets so where you are in the
world you have to judge
the carriers effect of the world will
take effect of that bullet as well so if
the world's going right your bullets
going right you're gonna have to put
more left on your reflection
and that's how it works
and if you're and if you've got a canton
as well the bullet's not going to go
straight so much into it you know it's
not all about just
lying down and shooting
okay let's join me once then tell us the
story behind
the pepsi
it's a weird thing to bring in
but um
my pepsi bowl now me and my number two
we got dropped off and we had to
move into a location
and as we were moving in it was in the
desert
middle of absolute nowhere i mean
you nothing around you and when the
helicopter takes off
you could hear a pin drop
you know
and that's when you look at your mate
you can go what are we doing
you know
but then we moved in we got our you know
got our marble straight and we tabbed in
and then we got mortared um it was
coming in and we hit the deck
and as i hit the deck
i hit a pepsi bottle
middle of nowhere
and it's worn on one side where the sand
had been worn and it's still got sand in
it
and i think
when i was lying there
thinking
please don't land on me please don't
land on me i was trying to make
how many words out of pepsi
so i was laying there with this pepsi
bottle
looking how many words i could make out
of pepsi and you know what to this day
now i probably couldn't make any either
no i'm not even getting shot at
you know but i picked up and put in my
backpack weighs nothing it's going to
take no space up
and i've had it ever since i've had it
ever since
sounds weird doesn't it but you poi
not saved my life but
it put me
in a calm situation
that's not silly at all
talk about what happened with the helmet
yeah basically
this is a mark six alpha helmet now when
i did my last tour all these new helmets
came out but my head is so vast
they never had one to fit my head so i
had to stick with the old-fashioned one
and i'm glad i did because the new ones
have got a high cut there
and as you can see i got shot on the
helmet
so the bullet came in there it went all
the way around and came out of the top
and it was an ak-47 short so it was
little round and
a but it's got three stages
so it's got um
supersonic as soon as it comes out
and then it's got transsonic where it
wobbles and if that bullet could talk
it'd be going oh yeah there we go there
we go and then it goes subsonic when it
slows down and he goes oh yeah oh so
i've sorted myself out now but it's it's
wasted so much energy for that transonic
stage so when it's gone subsonic it's
slowed down well this bullet was still
going supersonic when it hit me because
the distance that i got shot
basically i was on a mission and we had
to
secure a left flank
and
i didn't
i thought to myself when the mission is
set up i haven't checked over there
so i i went over there in my vehicle and
um
there were two taliban there um arming
up
and they rinsed me they rinsed me
i got hit in the helmet
which knocked me out believe it or not
he knocked me out for about 20 seconds
and
my other two vehicles came up to support
me
and and i realized that i got shot in my
man bag we call them man bags
because you put your magazines in i've
got shot foo there
[Music]
and obviously on the vehicle itself you
have a jimpi machine gun with an ammo
box that got shot
so i couldn't return fire
because everything was crushed
and um
to this day now
i cannot remember anything to this day
now because i got knocked out
does it feel strange looking at peaceful
equipment your life yeah it does yeah
yeah um
an inch lower and i won't be here now an
inch lower i wouldn't be here
and then
three weeks after that i got blown up by
a 30 kilo anti-tank mine
which i broke both my arms which i'm
still suffering with
and my hips and i got a brain injury
i've got a brain injury
yeah yeah
sure so we have a clean shot
thank you
glass of water or anything no i'm fine
mate
we got some close ups at the end of
that's all right yes cool
cheers
yeah
yes no let's go let's go on to talking
about how you left the army so
what made you did you want to leave
no
um
i got ptsd bad
i mean
severe ptsd complex ptsd you call it
now all the tools that i've done
through bosnia kosovo
um iraq afghan and i was getting
migraines a lot you know really bad
migraines and
i when i just go on a run i couldn't
walk afterwards because my hips were so
bad
and then
i never noticed it when we score and
exercise
i took it a step too far
i was acting like i was really on tour
i would take the lead
on charges and stuff like that because i
didn't want lads to get hurt
my wife noticed it first
she knows there's something wrong due to
my isolation
my
snappiness
my
just depression really and
suicidal thoughts
and then the army noticed it and i got
called into the mo's office which is the
medical officer's office
and he said we're going to discharge you
um
i was already in the mental health
um
sort of like
circle in the army you know but it got
to the point where
they said we're going to discharge you
and
from doing 20 odd years
took half an hour for me to get kicked
out
yeah i did want to go i didn't want to
go and i miss it now 2013 i left and to
this day now i miss it
to the core
if you put two duvets down on the floor
and one was black
and one was white
and on the black one it said anxiety
depression suicide
self-harm overdose
vile
regret
and then you had the white duvet
and it said peaceful
mellow
chilled out
happy
content
and i picked this black duvet up and i
threw it over you
and you're smothered that's exactly what
ptsd is
you can't breathe
it ruins and i i'm the first one to
admit it ruins your sex life
it ruins
your home life
ruins your friends because no one wants
to be around you because you're just
miserable
you don't want to go out because you get
so [ __ ] angry so quick
and no doubt when this goes out you know
people will say yeah but try this try
that try i've tried it
i've tried it and because i'm complex
i've not been in a car crash
you know
i've done tours
and i've seen things and i've done
things
so that's why they call it complex
because it's loads of different
scenarios which are hard to
address more than somebody who's just
been in a car crash
i wouldn't be here now
either sat talking to you guys or
on this planet if it wasn't for my wife
and my dog
no way
i would have checked out
yeah
and um
it's hard it's hard it's hard
betsy okay
she's um
little yorkshire terrier
i used to run ten miles a day
like five miles out five miles back and
she used to run with me
she's um 15 now
and
she saved my life she saved my life
you know
my um
yeah i'll say it my
wife
we went to america
um stayed there for a bit
and um
my wife went back to england to see her
mum
and i uh
yeah i nearly shot myself
i took all the rounds out the gun was
practicing where to do it
where i would do it
and
i put the bullet in cocked it
put it in my mouth
and betsy was sat on the back of the
sofa
and her head tilted
until the other way
and i just stared at her
yeah i sold it sold it
got rid of it
saved my life
and it's amazing you know
just amazing
is there anything that we haven't
covered do you want to say
read my book
read my book
yeah i wrote a book longest kill
and it's not a plug because it's been
out years
but
it tells you more about the tours that
i've done
without me crying
there's no pictures either
[Music]
this
[Music]
which war did you fight him
second world war
my fate was a third patella
and there was 12 of us
and we took part
in the north african campaign
and then we went on to the invasion of
sicily